bien on a maintenant passé à l'interview
nul en ébauche pas pendant le dinar
voilà les révolutionnaires risque c'est
bien
alors soyez concentré jean claude
gayssot est ce que vous préférez ce
matin venu là je vous avertis vous allez
voir c'est très nul les questions est ce
que vous préférez votre père votre mère
difficile je suis partagé peut-être ma
mère c'est dur votre père votre mère
l'aurait j'aimerais pas comme la couche
de roulement merde bah oui quoi je
dirais que tu répondes je me tourne en
perdre comme m
j'adore quand il dit que s'il veut
répondre à des questions là le projet
chez les travailleurs et ben non il y en
a eu la mode arrive salaire est gelé
répondre plus facilement vous préférez
staline ou hitler et pensions si vous ai
dit enfin pensé ok ah ça c'est nouveau
ici les communistes disait staline quand
même d'être le premier communiste que je
vois répond non je ne mens pas je suis
au mans bat mais je vous assure c'est
tout ça tout ce qu'on nous a mis à part
peut-être participer en appui c'est
nous-mêmes peut-être prêter à ce qu'on
nous colle à cette idée qu'on était
quand voulais faire comme là bas quand
vous qu'on était porteur de ces crimes
qu'ils ont commis tout ça peut-être là
dans notre façon d'être de les défendre
parce qu'il y avait le méchant loup
américaine qu'il fallait tout ça ça a dû
exister d'ailleurs y'a pas que y'a pas
que les communistes
bref en tout cas anelka je peux vous
dire que le communisme tel que nous le
concevons aujourd'hui la rien à voir ni
bien sûr avec khider l'a combattu à
mieux parti réfugié
c'est les communistes bon à partir de 41
cam jean claude en attendant tout cas
les biens dit pas ça a dit al partie
difficile j'étais obligé de vous parler
du pacte germano-soviétique oui
dzparis n'est pas terrible pacte
germano-soviétique koné puer compris à
ce moment là le soutenir je ne suis pas
fier de cela non ben je vous le dis
alors acquis trouvez-vous le plus de
circonstances atténuantes un vieux qui
se tape des jeunes ou moins jeunes qui
tapent sur des yeux un vieux qui se tape
des jeunes comme votre femme est là
un bien qui se tape déjà plus de cinq
ans en s'atténuant way we un ami
débarque chez vous la nuit à
l'improviste
ils rentrent ils s'approchent de la
table de nuit
vous dormez votre femme dort qu'est ce
qui vous gêne ray le plus qu'ils
trouvent sur la table de chevet un
godemichet ou mike michaels alors
attention jean claude gayssot est ce que
vous accepteriez de mourir comme ça
subitement là maintenant si cela devait
éradiquer pour toujours la pauvreté sur
la terre
si ça se devait oui oui mais comme je
suis sûr comme je dis aujourd'hui je
proche de l'esprit si on vous dit jamais
de pau vous allez mourir n'y aura plus
jamais de pauvres sur la terre oui oui
peut-être oui question compliquée on est
tous les deux dans un chalet c'est
l'hiver on est sous la neige
on a rien à bouffer moi je meurs de
froid tellement j'ai rien à manger
tellement il fait froid et pour survivre
êtes obligés de manger vous commencez
par quelles parties de mon corps
j'élimine tout ce qui risque d'amener la
le tuba comment s'appellent les prions
de la dame est criant ouais vous bouffez
pas les viscères jaj que les musclés je
touche pas tu as colonne vertébrale
atta mois les attend cerveau marc collat
fait avant ne pas le manger à votre
monarchiste vous allez vous employez
n'est encore bien alors attention à la
c'est votre entourage m'a demandé de ne
pas vous parler de vos origines turques
un an tant les satellites et de friches
de balladur je ne seriez plus gêné
d'être surpris par jacob donc au lit
avec deux vies ou un mec plus gênés avec
deux filles avec un mec ce nom mais
parce qu'un mec c'est pas possible
ah ouais avec tiger woods avoue qu'il
savait pas ce que match comme ça mène à
3 6 3 minutes pour convaincre bien
dernière question la plus compte tout si
vous étiez en vente dans un sex-shop
vous seriez quoi vous savez ce que c'est
qu'une branlette wii tm est une
branlette oui euh c'est la partie
médiane delà des cannes à pêche annonce
à saly à trois roues dans une canne à
pêche et la partie médiane s'appelle de
la branlette les personnes en jeu le
dire parce qu'il parle ce combo d'accord
on vous soyez une branlette voilà
nul